[MUSIC PLAYING]
SEAN GINEVAN: My
name's Sean Ginevan.
I work on the Android Enterprise
Business team at Google.
Our team is responsible for the
business-to-business success
of the Android platform.
We're a dedicated team of
engineers, product managers,
go-to-market folks, like
myself, who are ultimately
trying to make sure
that Android is
a great platform
for your employees
and for business transformation
projects that your company may
want to do.
And what I wanted to
do is give a little bit
of a history of some of the work
we've been doing on the Android
platform.
But more importantly,
introduce some marketing
go-to-market initiatives that
we've launched here at Google
to hopefully make understanding
how to adopt Android
into your organization easier
so you can focus on real things
like what you want to do
inside of your business.
From a employee enterprise
enablement perspective,
we've done a ton of
technical investment
in Android, going
all the way back
to the days of Android Lollipop.
In Android 5, we introduced
this concept of Android
for Work and two core features.
One which was the idea of
the work profile, which
helped organizations who wanted
to support BYOD, allow end
users to bring their own devices
in a way that would be secure,
such that basically
data applications
that you deploy to
that end user wouldn't
interact with
personal information
that the user may have.
And more importantly,
that was designed
to protect user privacy.
We wanted to make sure that
IT wasn't snooping on the file
system, the photos, the music,
anything else the user may
have brought with them.
We also, in parallel,
introduced features
for fully managed devices.
This was the idea that if
you're of thinking about things
in the old BlackBerry
world, the idea
that I can lock down the device,
the idea that I can whitelist
the applications that
go on that device
and have a relatively
full degree of control
over the hardware.
In every version
since Android 5,
we've done more
technical investment
into the Android platform.
We introduced better
support for what
we call corporate-owned
single-use or dedicated
devices.
These are the
barcode scanners you
see at places like
Walmart, offering
higher degree of control to make
sure that device is used only
for barcode scanning
and not, say, watching
YouTube on the job.
We introduced better support
for things like certificates.
And carrying on to Nougat, we
introduced improved usability
controls, like the
work profile challenge.
So that way, if I go through
and allow my nephew to go
and play with my device and
I turn off the work profile
so that way my nephew doesn't
play with my email account,
not that that
would ever happen--
the challenge with the passcode
before those applications
can be accessed.
We've introduced
features most recently
in Oreo called zero-touch.
This allows an
enterprise to make sure
that, as you unbox the device,
that device automatically
gets enrolled in for
management, automatically
gets provisioned with
corporate applications.
We're really elevating the
experience and activation
process that an end user
needs to go through.
And now, with Android
Pie, we've really
focused on a lot of
those frontline workers
that we've talked about
here at Cloud Next,
improving things like
shared device use cases,
support for multiple users,
and improving a lot of the
UX around the work profile,
making it easier to find
the applications that IT
has provisioned out to you.
To sort of up-level a lot
of what this looks like,
if you haven't adopted
Android Enterprise-- actually,
quick show of hands.
How many folks are actually
running Android inside
of your organization?
OK.
I think I can almost see
through the spotlights
and the projector.
How many of you are
running Android Enterprise?
OK.
Only a couple of you.
We'll talk about why that's
important in a minute.
But when you look at
the Android platform
and what you're
able to do with it,
it really allows you a
high degree of flexibility
when you start to
go and do things
that are more than just email.
Frankly, even if you are
just doing just email.
The personally-owned
world makes it such
that IT has very limited
control over what
you can do with that device.
You can only view and manage
the work applications,
you have very little
control over the device,
you can provision Wi-Fi.
That's about it.
VPN, that's about it.
And there's a high
degree of separation
between work and personal.
At a technical level,
what we're actually doing
is creating a
separate user space
on that device in the
work profile world.
It means that it's almost like
having two instances of Android
running on the same device.
File systems are
handled separately,
processes are isolated,
memory is isolated, even
cryptographically, the data
can be stored different.
And so it makes
sure that there's
a high degree of separation
between work and personal.
I can't just click open in
and share random data out
to Facebook.
On the company's
own side of things,
you enforce full control
over that device.
As I mentioned
earlier, that could
be as simple as whitelisting
what goes on that device.
It could be as complex as
creating a full launcher,
such that, really,
it almost feels
like the ticket kiosks you might
see here at the AMC theater.
I only see those
particular workflows.
I don't see anything
else on that device.
And you can optionally, on
those fully manage devices,
if you're using a corporate
liable as your mechanism
of ownership, so
you own the device,
you want to have a high degree
of control, most recently,
with Android 8, we allow
you to deploy a work profile
on those fully managed devices.
And what that
means is, you still
have that high degree of
control over the assets
you own but the end
user can go and bring
their own apps to
work, and there's still
that high degree of data
separation between the two.
So a ton of flexibility.
Virtually every use case that we
have encountered over the years
has been now tackled inside
of the Android Enterprise
framework.
We've also done a ton of
investment into security.
We believe that,
ultimately, Android
has to have a high
degree of security.
And that starts with
the operating system.
We really have a lot of
security tools baked in,
things like encryption,
things like secure boot,
so we actually validate
that the operating
system has booted properly.
We're doing things that
integrate the operating
system into the hardware.
So when you call cryptographic
functions in Android,
those keys get stored in
a dedicated secure element
on that device.
And we also are dedicating
the secure boot process
out to that secure element.
So it's a high
degree of assurance
that that device
hasn't been tampered
with before it interacts with
any of the corporate data
that you might
decide to put on it.
We have a lot of
management APIs that
allow you to easily
customize and tailor
and provision that
device experience.
And we hook all of this
up to Google Play Protect.
So Google Play
Protect, how many folks
are familiar with
Google Play Protect?
Few people?
For the rest of you that
aren't familiar with it,
Google Play Protect
is actually what
we're doing here at
Google to tackle malware
on Android as well as on
Android VMs in Chrome.
What we do is we scan
every application
that is in Google Play.
We are actually using our
web search technologies
to go and look out
to the broader web
and find applications that are
hosted outside of Google Play
and we scan those as well.
We can optionally, if the
user is opted into this,
look at the device itself,
pull applications off
of it that may have
been side loaded
and validate those as well.
And what that means
is, every day,
we're scanning, give or take, 50
billion different applications
to flag for what
those applications are
and whether they can
be potentially harmful.
There's always
work to do on this,
but since we
launched this program
it is less likely that you
will die in your bathtub
than find malware
in Google Play.
It used to be that we
use a less likely--
to continue with the
morbidity thread--
that you'd be less likely
to get hit by lightning.
But we've since
actually broadened
our definition of malware.
We're hunting for more things
here at Google in order
to create a safe
environment for end users.
And as we go and look for
more broader sets of things
that are potentially
harmful, obviously,
we're cracking down as well.
A lot of the data that we look
at from a security perspective
is also exposed out
to you as developers.
There's an entire suite inside
Android called SafetyNet,
and that allows you to
query for things like,
did the device boot properly?
Has Google Play Protect
found malware on this device?
Are my cryptographic keys
still not been tampered with?
And so you can actually have
a high degree of certainty
certainly through
your management APIs
but also you as developers can
actually query for that data
to make sure that the
device is in a secure state
before any data is handled.
Now, I like to think
from a Google perspective
we're doing quite well,
but it's always better
to have validation
from third parties.
Gartner has gone through
and done a recent analysis
of various mobile
operating systems that
are in the market--
Android and others.
And the key thing to
look at in this chart
are Android 8 and
then Android on Pixel,
which is sort of a very
pure version of Android.
And the key thing also
to know in this chart
is that dark blue is better.
And so in Gartner's own
analysis-- and there's
a whole video up on
YouTube that will walk us
through how this
analysis was done,
talks to Dave Kleidermacher,
our VP of security.
But the point here
is that Gartner,
in this objective
analysis, found
that Android has a
higher degree of security
and deeper level of
feature integration
from a security perspective than
other platforms in the market.
So with the security
issue tackled,
or certainly an ongoing
thing that we've
tackled, one question we
wanted to look at Mobile World
Congress two years
ago was, how do we
make it easier for you all
to procure devices and, more
importantly, get those
devices under management?
We know that at
the end of the day
business transformation
happens through apps,
and we want to make sure
that these devices can
be easily unboxed and
very easily be enrolled
into whatever mobility
management toolset
you're using so you can leverage
tools like Manage Google Play.
And in the last year, we've
seen over 50 different resellers
join the zero-touch program.
These are resellers that can
actually sell you a device
and actually activate
it through zero-touch.
30 of those joined in just
second half of 2018 alone.
So this is a program that
we continue to expand
and we want to make sure that
we're working with the leading
resellers that you all
rely on to make sure
that you have this great
experience from the Android
platform.
So with all the
things that we're
doing on the platform
side of things,
and with all the things we're
doing around zero-touch,
the question we get
from customers is,
how do I know it's
enterprise ready?
I mentioned to you
that back in Android 5
is when we started our
technological investment
on Android.
But in Android 6 is where
we made it mandatory.
We actually mandated
that developers and OEMs
who were building
Android devices,
they had to adopt the
Android Enterprise framework
as a part of what
we call the CDD--
the compatibility
definition document.
And what that
basically means is,
devices will come with
Android Enterprise
as a part of that framework.
In fact, you can go through
and buy a $50 Android Go
device in India unlocked,
and it will be enrollable
into a mobility
management system,
like Google Cloud
Identity Manager.
Do I think that
that $50 Android Go
device is what you
should be deploying
to all of your employees?
Probably not.
There's a lot of
trade-offs with Android Go,
including around things
like horsepower and memory
to get to that $50 price point.
In fact, the Android team
has built an entire suite
of Go apps that are optimized
for these really low bandwidth,
low memory environments.
And the likelihood that
your Enterprise apps,
like SAP and like
Salesforce, will
run as well as you would
expect, is probably pretty low.
So with so much availability
on the Android platform
being out there, we really
wanted to answer this question
and help our customers
answer this question, which
is, what can I buy
in the market that
is going to be Enterprise class,
not just Enterprise ready?
And so we thought about this
from a technical perspective,
working with our customers,
we identified three core areas
that they brought up to us.
One was confidence
and selection.
So what they were asking
us was, if I buy a device
and I'm particularly a
multinational organization--
any multinationals here?
A few of you?
So are those devices going to be
available on a worldwide basis?
Can I buy them unlocked and
allow my employee in London,
my employee in New York,
and my employee in Singapore
to get that device and
have that device run
inside of my organization?
The second is consistency
and deployment.
What we wanted to make sure
was that end users, when they
enroll their devices to get
access to corporate data
and get access to
applications, we're
having a consistent experience.
Now, this is not
saying that we want
to prevent the OEMs from
innovating on top of UX.
We don't want-- the Huaweis
of the world, as an example--
to stop using their
UI frameworks.
What we do want
to do is make sure
that the enrollment
workflows and the settings
workflows to get connected
into your enterprise
were largely consistent.
And that's what
we've been working on
with our OEM partners.
And finally, we wanted
to make sure that devices
were current and up-to-date.
We wanted to make
sure that when you
buy a device, that these devices
were going to get patches
at least once every 90 days,
and that they would be getting
those patches for a
minimum time period,
and that those devices would get
at least one dessert upgrade.
What we call a dessert
upgrade here at Google
is a major feature
update of Android.
And what that means is,
going from, as an example,
Android 8 Oreo to Android 9 Pie.
The desserts are in the names.
And so those were the
really three criteria
that we saw from customers.
We then went to the over
200 OEMs that we worked with
and we asked them, who would
like to join this program?
Who is going to sign up to
this elevated set of criteria?
And who is going to go
and also commit, frankly,
to things like
training, making sure
that they understand Android
and they can position it
well to their customers?
And since then, we've
had 12 OEMs bring over
60 different devices
to market that are
part of the Android Enterprise
Recommended portfolio.
These devices, a lot of the
ones I decided to throw up here
on the slide, are
flagship devices,
just because those are
the shiniest ones that
are out there.
But it also represents a lot
of different price points.
You can now go and work with the
likes of Nokia, Huawei, and LG
and find devices that are at
that $150 to $300 price point
so you can support things like
corporate liable deployments
of Androids.
This is not just a
program targeted at $700
and up from a
flagship perspective.
It really is every price
point along that graph.
And so we're seeing
a lot of success.
I'll talk about that in a minute
of just customers starting
to really think
about this program
and using it as a way to
help them procure devices
more easily.
But we got a bit
of a poke, which
was, that's great for
knowledge workers,
but what if I'm a Walmart?
What if I'm using Android
across my entire organization,
from the logistics warehouse all
the way out to the store front?
Those devices, as great
as the Google Pixel 3 is,
I've seen videos [INAUDIBLE]
did a really cool case
study with Walmart
and material design,
looking at how those devices
are used in the warehouse.
The Pixel 3 is
probably not going
to go and hold up to the
abuse that a guy who's
trying to stack
pallets at Walmart
is going to go and put on it.
And so the good news is that
Android's a very open platform.
We work with a lot
of different OEMs
to build really unique
devices, devices
that are really built to suit
for a lot of different use
cases.
And one of those use cases
is the ruggedized market.
IDC has, in a few different
research publications,
highlighted that Android
is the next logical choice
for the rugged market, as
Microsoft has end-of-lifed
the Windows CE platform.
And we're really
excited to be working
with leading OEMs, like Zebra,
like Honeywell, like Panasonic,
and Sonim, Point Mobile,
Datalogic, Moto, and Motorola
Solutions, and Bluebird.
This really represents many
of the purpose-built OEMs
and ruggedized
OEMs in the market.
And when we built the criteria
for Enterprise Recommended
for rugged, we
knew that was going
to be different than what
we should be thinking
about for knowledge workers.
We wanted to make sure that
Enterprise Recommended was
tackling things
like drop testing,
tackling things like dust
intrusion and water intrusion.
In fact, if you go down to
the show floor later today
or tomorrow, we have
many of these devices
up in the Android
Enterprise Recommended area
in the workplace
transformation pavilion.
So you can get a feel for
what those devices look like.
So what's important to note
here is that this is not just
us going to the market
and saying, hey, sign up
and we'll slap a badge on it.
We're actually validating
that these devices
are meeting these criteria.
We're looking at those
workflows for enrollment
and making sure that
those devices are
doing the things that are part
of the Enterprise Recommended
criteria.
We're going through
and looking at how
these devices act when they're
under enterprise management.
We're not drop-testing devices.
That is an area where
we look to the partners
to show us validation
around things
like IP ratings and the like.
But we are actually
independently looking
at these devices to ensure
they're meeting our criteria.
And so far, we've seen a lot
of really positive reaction
from the market.
Data from HMD Global, which is
a manufacturer of Nokia devices,
has found that many--
and over 56% of folks are aware
of the Enterprise Recommended
program.
But more importantly, they're
really looking to the program
to make purchasing decisions.
And data from a recent
survey in Europe from IDC
said that, I think as a result
of a lot of the security
investment we've been
putting into Android,
they believe that those devices
that have been validated
by Google and that are using the
latest and greatest of Android
actually can be more
secure than iOS.
And we're seeing a variety of
different organizations really
look toward Enterprise
Recommended as their way
of supporting or the Android
platform inside of their IT
organization.
HSBC is one of those, and
HSBC has come out publicly
and stated that they will
only look toward Enterprise
Recommended devices as they
send out requests for proposals
for corporate liable, as they
think about their BYOD catalog
inside the bank.
The notable point also
is that Android is really
being proven across those most
sensitive verticals, places
like financial services,
and government,
and health care, and the like.
SAP is another partner
that has actually come
out very publicly and said
that Enterprise Recommended was
a key initiative for them,
and specifically for BYOD.
A lot of people think about
BYOD as bring your own device.
And I know I'm not
in the recording.
I am widening my arms
as wide as I can.
But the idea here is that
the challenge with that
is, can IT assure
that these devices are
going to actually be
secure and be handling
corporate data properly?
And so many
organizations, like SAP
and like HSBC, when they
start their BYOD programs,
they really say,
here are the catalog
of devices we will allow
into our organization.
BYOD doesn't mean bring
your own everything.
It means, if you want
to support Android,
here are the Android devices
we're willing to let in.
If we want to support
other platforms,
here is the catalog that
you can choose from.
And we really see
a lot of success
from our customers when they
use that method to launch
their BYOD initiatives
inside of their company.
So I mentioned it's really
around these three criteria.
But as we've rolled out the
hardware program early last
year-- or I guess almost
two years ago now--
we heard from our customers
that these were really
good initiatives to helping
us figure out hardware.
But hardware is
not the be all end
all of a mobility deployment.
There's a lot of
cases where there's
additional services, additional
support, additional software
that I might want to roll
out into my organization.
How do I know that
those are going
to be meeting a
similar set of criteria
and will be successful inside
of my mobility deployment?
And so, this year, we launched
Android Enterprise Recommended
services, which was
really in response
to what we were hearing from
customers around validating
the broader set of ecosystem
that Android supports
beyond just hardware.
And we focused on
two core areas.
One is enterprise
mobility management,
so the suite of services that
are managing devices inside
of your organization, as well
as managed service providers.
So this is the actual partner,
the technical partners,
who may be offering deployment
and support services
to assist your IT departments.
The EMM requirements really
focused on these four key areas
on the slide, but
one was making sure
that EMMs were stepping up to
the variety of different ways
the Android can be deployed.
When an EMM partner
works with Google,
we actually do
validate the solution
sets, whether it's fully
managed, work profile,
dedicated.
We validate that those
particular software
implementations, whether they're
Enterprise Recommended or not,
correspond to the technical
specs that we author.
But what we were finding
is that not every EMM
offered every deployment style.
At the same time, IT was
trying to go through and use
Android in a variety of
different deployment scenarios.
I mentioned Walmart
as an example.
You can imagine how you
deploy a device at Walmart
or at Marks and Spencer
on the store floor
is very different than
how you might deploy
Android inside the
accounting department
or the other parts of
the carpeted enterprise
inside of those organizations.
And so we really
wanted to validate
that advanced feature
sets from at least two
of the different deployment
mechanisms of Android
Enterprise.
Two of the three were supported.
We wanted to make sure also that
these partners were offering
dedicated technical leadership.
I actually came from MobileIron
before I joined Google.
In many cases, EMMs
act as the front line
of support for many
mobility deployments
because it's the glue
that's holding things
together and actually activating
the deployment devices
inside of corporate IT.
And so we wanted to make sure
that these organizations did
two things.
One was that, in
managing Android,
Android Enterprise would be
the default and primary mode
of management that
these pieces of software
would be using inside
of deployments.
And two, that there was guidance
and documentation for customers
that were either
rolling out or migrating
to Android Enterprise.
We really wanted to make sure
that best practices from Google
were well-established
not just from ourselves
but from these
technical partners that
are going out and helping
customers deploy Android
inside of their enterprise.
We wanted to make sure
that they were offering
Enterprise-level support.
So we've actually been
doing a lot of training
from Google of these
partners to make sure
that if you call a given
EMM, they understand--
at least their escalation
teams will well understand
the Android platform.
They can troubleshoot how
Androids deployed inside
of an organization.
And finally, we
really wanted to make
sure there was a proven
ability to deploy,
that these particular partners
had worked with large IT
organizations, had demonstrable
success with these IT
organizations, and frankly
made sure that their field
organizations-- their
sales and technical sales
specialists-- were
well-trained by Google
about Android Enterprise so
that the relevant technical
knowledge was being
conveyed to the customer.
We're really excited
by the traction
we're getting in the early
days of Enterprise Recommended.
We've had so far nine
partners join this program.
Many of these are
the ones that are
in the top right of
various market surveys,
whether they be from
Forrester, Gartner, or IDC.
And we really are
pleased with the level
of technical
leadership that they're
bringing to the table in support
of your enterprise mobility
deployments.
The second area was around
managed service providers.
There's a lot of
organizations, particularly
if you look at the
desktop world, that
have decided to outsource
frontline support
or outsource the deployment
services for platforms
like Windows, Mac,
and even Chromebook.
And so we wanted to make
sure, as organizations
start to look toward their
mobility deployments being
handled in the same way, that
managed services providers were
really, really well
trained and offered
a high degree of technical depth
in supporting your deployments.
So again, it really falls
in these three core areas
of confidence in
selection, that these folks
are validated and
trained by Google,
that they have proven
expertise, that they have
consistent training and
standardized on escalation
processes from Google,
and that they're always
current on the latest
training requirements,
and frankly, that they
routinely collaborate
with us on business objectives.
Android is obviously an
ever-evolving platform,
and so we do want to make
sure that our partners, both
the EMMs as well as the MSPs,
are continually keeping up
to date in the services that
they're bringing to the market.
From a deeper dive into where
that platform looks like,
we mandate that 80% of the sales
and technical sales specialists
are trained in what we
call Android Academy.
So Android Academy is a program
we launched about 18 months
ago, designed to make
sure that the best
practices and
knowledge of Google
is out there in the market.
For those of you
that are curious,
it's up at
AndroidEnterprise.training.
And that is designed to
target toward two core areas.
One is sales specialists,
that you understand
how to do basic positioning
of the Android platform,
that you understand
that Android is secure
and that it can be used
to do really cool things
around business transformation.
And then it dives
into a higher degree
of technical depth for
technical sales specialists,
so not just that Android is
secure but actually how Android
offers that security,
how that security is
integrated to the hardware
so you can position
that data to your customer.
We've since expanded
that program
through an invite-only program
called the Android Enterprise
Experts program.
And that really takes a much
deeper set of validation
to the individual.
We're actually going
through-- and what
we'll show you in a minute.
I'll just show you now.
We actually are taking
folks into the lab
and we're making sure they know
how to troubleshoot something
if something goes wrong.
We introduced failure
scenarios that we've
seen from actual
deployments and make sure
that the support and
deployment engineers know
how to troubleshoot through
these particular processes.
And these MSP trainings
were run by Google.
These were our partner and
customer engineering teams
from Mountain View,
New York, and London,
that traveled around
the world to train
all of these individuals.
And so when we
launched the program,
mandated that the partners have
at least two Android Enterprise
experts and two Android Support
engineers in each region
that they serve.
We also mandated that these
folks be trained on EMMs
and that they actually
be trained-- and I think,
I believe, at least two EMMs--
and finally, that they have
demonstrative technical ability
through customer deployments and
deploying Android Enterprise.
Since we launched
the program, we've
had some of the leading
organizations in Enterprise
Mobility Services step up to
the plate and join this program.
Leading brands like Accenture,
and Cognizant, and DXC,
and Econocom, and
Honeywell have ponied up
the technical resources
needed to ensure
that they are offering great
services to the market.
And I've been in mobility
for quite some time.
I've very rarely
seen engineers get
nervous in training programs.
But the Android
Expert program was
one of those where folks were
definitely put to the test,
and we're super excited to
have these partners joining us.
So when we [INAUDIBLE] get
this from a holistic level,
we've really been investing
on a program-by-program basis
to make sure that all of the
different partners that you
work with are well served by
the best knowledge from Google,
the best validation
of the services
that these folks provide,
that the software we provide
is being incorporated
into these product suites,
and that this evolves over time.
With every release
of Android, we're
continuing to evolve the
technical requirements
for devices, the training
requirements for EMMs and MSPs,
and so this will be an evolving
program where you'll see,
hopefully, new partners
join the program
but certainly also
there's an assurance
that these partners
are validated
as new versions of
Android come out.
I'll leave you with this.
I asked the beginning
of this presentation,
how many folks were
running Android,
and lots of different
hands went up.
And then I asked how many of you
were running Android Enterprise
and not as many hands
went up, only a few.
For those of you
that are running
Android inside of your
organization, many of you
may have been using
legacy software to do it.
There was a suite of tools we
offered prior to Android 5,
called Device Administrator.
It offered basic client-side
APIs to set a device passcode,
to turn off hardware like
Bluetooth or the camera.
And these were
really basic tools,
almost like the very
basic suite of policies
that came with active sync
in the early days of Windows
Mobile.
We've since deprecated a lot
of those client-side APIs.
In Android 9, we actually
deprecated passcode and device
hardware controls
in documentation.
So if you call those
APIs on Android 9,
you'll get an error saying,
this isn't supported anymore.
In Android 10, we're actually
going to turn those APIs off.
So if your organization is
looking to actually support
Android from an IT
management perspective,
it's really important that
you be looking to the Android
Enterprise framework to
actually roll this out
in your organization.
Up on our blog at blog.google in
the Android Enterprise product
update section, there's a
blog post and a blue book
that we've launched
to help you understand
how to tackle that migration,
to take a cap and growth
strategy to your
Android deployment
to make sure that the
latest device is enrolling
can actually work in the
Android Enterprise framework.
And certainly, from
our perspective,
we're making sure that
our mobility management
partners and our
services partners
are well trained to help
you through that journey.
[MUSIC PLAYING]